Now let's begin with another view of calibration.
So you're probably wondering, why is calibration required?
Well, in order to create accurate compositions from CG renders and live video in Unreal Engine,
a virtual camera that accurately simulates the physical camera used to capture the real-world video footage is required.
This is also really useful if you're going to do any kind of set extension.
If you don't do lens calibration before you do any of your set extension,
you're not going to have the data necessary to pass on to the departments requiring that information in order to complete your shots.
The virtual camera position and orientation in these situations must closely match the position and orientation
of the physical camera and the physical camera tracking information
that must match the exact timing of the video feed to ensure each video frame is accurately synced to the position and orientation of the camera at any given time.
Now, when completed correctly, it is possible to evaluate the calibrated lens file for any focus and zoom position by interpolating between the stored focus and zoom points.
Now as we go through the calibration process, the camera calibration and OpenCV lens distortion plugins allow Unreal Engine to model the physical lens distortion needed
to accurately align the virtual camera to the physical camera and introduces the lens file asset used to store all of the calibration data for camera and lenses.
One thing to note is that the calibrated lens data can vary depending on the camera's focus and zoom.
In order to achieve a high quality calibration, multiple focus and zoom points should be captured during the calibration process.
Now, before we get started, I do want to jump into Unreal Engine.
There are a few folders that we need in our calibration folder in order to actually put things in order and keep them organized as we calibrate our camera for the engine.
Now, you'll see here that I'm over in my content browser and I already have an existing calibration folder.
I also have my media profile and my media profile bundle folder located within my calibration folder.
So you see here I've got my media profile and my media profile inner assets.
Now, the folders I need in my calibration folder are my Aruco wall textures.
So I'm going to go ahead and create a brand new folder and I'm going to name this Aruco Wall Textures.
This is going to be used to store our Aruco wall textures in our next course.
Next, we're going to need another new folder. We're going to call this one Checkerboard.
We're going to need this when we create our Checkerboard for calibration of our lens distortion map.
Next, we need to get another folder here that we're going to call Lens Files.
Now, this is where we're going to keep all the lens files that we create for each individual camera and lens combination.
Any time that you create a new lens and camera combination, you will need a new lens file.
And finally, we're going to create a new folder for NotalPoint.
And this is where we store the objects we use for NotalPoint calibration.
Now, if you want to stay organized and just keep these separate, you can go ahead and create a new folder
and call this Media Profiles and move your inner assets along with your media bundle, media source, media output,
and media profile in one single location.
It is recommended, though, when you do create your media profiles that you generate this folder before you do that.
Now, in order to make sure that you have this working correctly, you'll notice that this folder is now empty
and a duplicate was created inside this Media Profiles folder.
So, that's it for this section. In our next section, we will discuss some of our camera configurations.